hi
i'm roger ross williams i'm an
african-american man
with dreadlocks all kind of bunched up
in a little bun
on top of my head i am in brooklyn new
york
um in my office and behind me is a
bookshelf
with um some sort of obnoxious awards
and uh it's great to be here hi i'm jim
lebron
i'm a 64 year old white man i've got
longish curly hair and a green goatee
and i've got glasses on i'm
sitting in my home office which is uh on
the back behind me is a red wall with
some music and uh movie posters hi
i'm bao nguyen i'm a 36 year old asian
american man
with black hair um and a black beard
i have uh i'm wearing a black
polo i'm in my studio in los angeles and
uh behind me are a large bay of windows
um a sofa and uh some books and posters
um hi i'm don porter i am
a medium brown skinned
woman of a certain age in my prime
i am upstairs in my home office
with a very cute modern chair next to me
with a red cushion
i have on a kind of pink
plaid uh shirt and my hair is short
and curly natural
uh hi my name is lisa cortez
i am an afro latina
my skin is cocoa brown kissed by the sun
i have dreadlocks i am wearing white
glasses a black dress with a blue and
green and gold necklace
the walls behind me are red and i am
speaking from sugar hill in harlem
welcome to the next episode of academy
dialogues it starts with us
our continuing series of conversations
about race ethnicity
gender history opportunity and the art
of filmmaking
hosted by the academy my name is sean
finney
and our topic today is documentaries
through our lens
we're honored to have five highly
awarded documentary filmmakers
join us for this discussion about the
challenges people from underrepresented
communities still face in the
documentary world
our moderator is the prolific filmmaker
and academy governor
roger ross williams roger is an
award-winning director
producer writer and became the first
african-american director to win an
academy award
with his short film music by prudence
joining roger will be director producer
lisa cortez filmmaker jim
lebrecht director and producer
bow win and filmmaker don porter
we look forward to your conversation
welcome everybody
thank you for coming today and
participating in this
in the dialogues um i
wanted to start um you know so
the conversation about who gets to tell
the story is not a new one
we all know that um we've traditionally
been
defined uh through other through other
people's lenses
uh the documentary industry has been
seen as a whole as
progressive um as someone as a community
that
is actually sort of ahead of the game in
the entertainment
business but i think the dirty little
secret is
you know the documentary community is
not that um
ahead of the game and then we have a lot
of work to do
um i want wanted to start by sort of
taking
um your your temperature about kind of
the state
of documentary for people from
underrepresented communities
and where you think we are right now and
i'm gonna
and since you all are coming from
different perspectives um
and i'm gonna start with the elder
statesman here don
porter
um well it's it's a joy a privilege to
be here with all of you
who uh work i respect so much and i
appreciate you all
being here and of course um uh
the greatest admiration love and respect
and honor to my governor
um so um you know i i think that we are
at a very strange
time um coming off of
the idea and the you know common
wisdom that they're this is the golden
age of documentary and there's more work
than ever
and there's more appetite and audience
appetite and there's particularly
an appetite for stories about
underrepresented peoples
um i think um that's
a testament just to how broad and vast
the audience is the audience likes to
you know to see themselves on screen
um and yet um you know when i think
about who the creators are
that are being asked to tell those
stories i do not
see the demand meeting the supply
and i mean that by i
you know have the kind of feeling
that while there is demand for
stories about people from
underrepresented communities
i don't see the kind of gatekeepers or
people with the funds to make those
stories happening
i don't see a really wide net
being cast and and i think that that's
a big problem and you know one thing
um i think this conversation is
necessary but it's also hard and
it's hard um because
the documentary there is a community
here and we do
work together or we appear in panels or
we support each other we help each other
and so i think people are have been a
little reticent to criticize
when filmmakers um take on projects
that maybe there's another voice that's
better suited to take on that project
so so i welcome this conversation i'm
going to be honest about my feelings
about it
but i think we need to push
the people who can really green light
make films happen
to look beyond the very narrow group of
filmmakers that they
are are looking to to tell these stories
that there's a demand for
so i'll start yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely
bal your um new
you know a relatively young filmmaker um
and um uh
just i'd like to just talk to you about
your perspective with someone who is um
you know i guess beware i guess be what
is your first film
um someone's sort of starting out in the
in the doc industry
and what what your observations are um
well
i just wanted to also express my
gratitude for being invited to this
really
amazing panel of fellow filmmakers i
really respect as well
um b water was actually my second film
but my first film
uh was not in the way that i
i really wanted to tell that story and i
think
a lot of the times as filmmakers
we feel like it's necessarily to tell it
to a certain audience
we're often asked like oh how does this
story relate to
a western audience to an american
audience to to a white audience
and some of that really kind of um
i think filters our own voice in a way
you know
that feels inauthentic and it's not
honest
and what i found with making be water
which i was so fortunate and privileged
to make
was that i could tell a story that was
unapologetically asian-american that was
unapologetically about bruce lee's
struggle
as an asian american in hollywood and i
think that
is shifting a bit but i recognize that
it it sort of becomes a trend in the
industry that
we can have these like periods of okay
we're going to have
films that are very authentic and then
we're going to pat ourselves on the back
about it but
is it something that's sustainable over
time and
i think um learning from bruce lee
actually
i i understood what it meant to be
authentic as as a filmmaker as a
storyteller
i've used those lessons to sort of try
to push myself for as a filmmaker
as a documentary filmmaker and not think
so much of like oh how does this connect
to
the western audience how does this
connect to a white american audience
it's like
i should think of myself as as an
audience member that matters as well
right
and i think we are often told in terms
of these spaces for documentary
filmmakers
um especially in development it's really
hard to get films
developed because we're i think
many bipac marginalized
filmmakers they're not seen for their
potential we have to like
live up to a higher threshold of success
than a lot of other filmmakers out there
who personally have the same experience
in terms of
um work experience but i think we have
to also think about the value
of our experience as you know
marginalized communities as marginalized
individuals and
not think about the price of
representation but the value of
representation more
yeah absolutely absolutely
lisa you um you came from the scripted
world
uh produced precious um and uh
your your second documentary um
all in the fight for democracy is i was
dropping to today or tomorrow
um i i just is do you see a difference
in the doc community from the
scripted community and what is that
well um
i i i i'm not different in it
in in how i operate in either
um i love what bao said about being
unapologetic
in your voice in your vision
and oftentimes you know
what we're trying to figure out is how
did we arrive at this moment and with
this story
and for myself i am looking
to center my
the value of my experience
and what it brings to the project
and so and my responsibility to my
communities
so whether it's scripted or narrative
i kind of my north star as a creator
um doesn't change
jim i think i feel like um
often um differently abled people
are left especially differently but
filmmakers are left
out of the conversation i've been on
many
um uh sort of diversity panels i've
you know and and when we when we were
talking about diversity we often leave
out
um people with disabilities um i
you know i made a film about um
a young woman with a disability and i
was
i was my eyes were open to my own
sort of sort of bias my own um
you know being uncomfortable um and and
i ha and i
it was a huge learning curve to learn to
sort of
um exist in that community and sort of
and sort of understand who they are and
as as they were all young people
in africa um i just you know i want to
ask you
um uh to talk a little bit about that
and about
um sort of in in the documentary
community
about what you know sort of voices like
yours and why we're not
hearing from a lot of a lot of people
with disabilities
well thank you for that question and i
also want to echo
how absolutely honored i am to be with
all of you today and to be part of this
discussion
um and and to be honest with you i i
think that
just my presence here today is kind of
what the issue is is that
just getting in the door simply being in
the room
um has been difficult for a lot of
people with disabilities
and indeed i was seen just a few years
ago i was seeing all these different
diversity and inclusion movements
including at the ida at the
international
documentary association you know when
they had getting real
in in 2016 the convention
it was all about kind of inclusion and
stuff and there wasn't anything
about disability and
so but i've seen a lot of really
positive change
and the the ida really embraced that
and really addressed that and when they
had getting real
uh two years ago we had panels on
disabled filmmakers and we had a
convening
of disabled filmmakers and
allies and that was the first time that
people
actually different film filmmakers with
all sorts of different
disabilities or if they were deaf or
hard of hearing
we're in the same room with each other
so i think that people are finally
starting to recognize
that we are a marginalized community
and that what we are dealing with is a
civil rights issue in our community
that it's not purely like medical these
two these people are sick
but that really this is
about being part of society so
i'm i'm more optimistic though than i
was a couple years ago
great um you used you know you talked
about diversity
um and includes those words and i want
to
talk a little bit about those terms and
you know
how many how many panels have we seen
about
diversity about you know using throwing
around these
terms there's every now with this sort
of you know racial reckoning happening
in america
there's you know every corporation you
know the entertainment industry everyone
is sort of
jumping on this sort of you know
diversity
using the word diversity and jumping on
this bandwagon um for me
um it it it feels like
it's um that diversity
means um assimilation it means um
we have to fit within you know they want
a a person of color a person
um with a disability they want them in
the room
but just to reinforce their own um
their own their own their own ideology
their own their own way that they've
always done things
not really um opening the door to our
voices and our stories
so i would just want to go around and i
want to
to ask each one of you um how do you
define
diversity inclusion these terms how do
you define diversity and what does it
sort of
mean to you and i'll um i'll i'll start
with you
don porter um i think you know there's
there's uh you know we
in the black community we always say
like we don't
you know usually have the opportunity to
hide our
difference because you know i wear my
difference proudly
and happily um but i think that there
are um i i'm very concerned
about people who are not wealthy
um people from other areas who are not
from new york city or from you know los
angeles or san francisco
um you know people from the middle of
the country i feel like
um there there is a
the reason that we want authentic voices
is because we want to
do something approximating truth and so
i really love
what bows saying about you know
whatever our differences are and that
begs the question
is what are we comparing to right
um but whatever our individual
experiences are that is a that is a gift
that is
that is you know what we want to
encourage so
um i i do really try and think hard
about economic diversity um geographic
diversity and uh you know life
experience you know you could no matter
what
race you are if you come from a you know
a really you know kind of
difficult financial circumstance i think
you do have a different perspective
on uh on issues and i think that that's
those are voices that
are are really should be encouraged
yeah yeah um jim
i often uh i often kind of think about
this as who's not in the room
you know if i'm really looking about
inclusion
and indeed you know what dawn has talked
about here
uh is really important i mean i i never
thought about people who are
simply geographically marginalized
and and their ability to be able to tell
their stories
so um and even within the disabled
community
there's such a wide umbrella so there
are people with cognitive issues there
are
people with mental health issues that
they're dealing with
and that it's important for us to make
sure that we are
really not leaving anybody behind in
regards to
how we are looking out for each other
and i think that for
for me personally that obviously goes
well beyond just disability
but that my experience informs how i
look at anybody that i'm working with
and when i check and see who's not in
the room
yeah yeah yeah well
yeah i mean it's like what angelos davis
said right like diversity is a corporate
strategy and i feel like it's becoming
more and more that way
in many conversations and uh i mean i
appreciate that this
conversation is the word diversity isn't
part of the panel
title right um and i think it's all
about like
how we center anything in the world
what's the standard what's considered
normal and
when we diverge from that it's that's
what diversity is considered right but
who determines what the center is what
what the center of our narratives are
what the center
what the gold standard is what what's
the center you know of of merit what's
the center of success and
even um thinking geographically like you
know western cinema western films is
considered kind of the gold standard of
success but i think
uh even this past year with parasite
winning i thought it was very
encouraging because we're re-centering
what the best picture is in a way
right and when you think of that it just
opens up the opportunities it opens up
our borders of
of not just thinking about the west as
being the center of the world and i
think
uh given um you know how global
uh how globally we're connected and and
trying to build community especially
through film um
documentaries in a way i think have been
a bit more progressive
in that if you look at you know the best
documentary nominations last year
honeyland for sama i think those
opportunities to rethink the center and
how we're centering
narratives is important when we're
thinking about diversity because to me
you know a white male is diverse right
uh someone brought that up in an earlier
uh
academy dialogue and i was like that's
perfect like for me i'm not diverse i
am exist as who i am and like don was
saying when when you're
around your community you don't feel
diverse you just feel like you're there
you're you're you're allowed to be there
you're allowed to exist so
i think think rethinking you know as
we're reckoning a lot of things in in
america in the world we have to also
think of
what it means to be diverse exactly
i i love that you know most of the world
i was dr when i was
driving here i was thinking you know
most of the world is not
you know a white european
centered um reality perspective and i
and and so what is this so what does
diversity mean it means that we're
trying to fit within that
we're trying to you know the types of
films we make everything we do we're
trying to like are we trying to like fit
within that
that sort of their sort of reality
trying to assimilate
um uh but to be in um to be an
anti-racist
um you you know it's not about
assimilating into into anyone's
um reality it's about your own
communities like dawn sets about
who you are in your own community um so
i think that's that's
that's really important part of the the
the conversation here
um lisa he's a quartet
well roger i think you know sonny um
we've talked a lot about
diversity inclusion but
then measuring it against progress like
who is getting awarded
the projects who has the access to the
funding
and um you know i i'm
i'm dreaming of a world where we can
stop having
the conversations because we will see
that
tangible progress has been made
in terms of who's getting projects
and more importantly that otherness
is not being used as
a way of diminishing the value of what
we work
create and the visibility
of what we create um
in this conversation we have to look at
privilege
and you know because that is certainly
one of
the boundaries that also comes
into this conversation
um whatever privilege
decision makers are
[Music]
working from is it we have all seen has
been a deterrent
you know that those gatekeepers have
introduced
so you know this is a an interesting
time
it's a time of reckoning um and i think
if we all want to get
to truth in our work in this
business and in our storytelling
we have to have these very difficult
conversations
and move beyond the conversation
to action yeah there was
something you said about um you know
as governor you know um and as someone
who
um heads up the uh the uh documentary
diversity committee
i've actually had filmmakers um complain
to me that
good old sort of american american films
are not being nominated
you know that um too many
foreign films they'll sound familiar too
many foreign films
are getting nominated in the documentary
category
that there were two films from syria
last year you know i
and it just blows my mind that i'm that
but like that
the the the the privilege and the that
that you are you are entitled because
you are um
an american which means you are you know
sort of
this is a code word for you know sort of
white
um white filmmakers who have dominated
this
the doc branch um so
that has been a um a big sort of pet
peeve of mine so
i just had to say that um
how much um you know you guys are all
all of you um are all
really successful you all have um
major major films that are
just with big distributors and
your your names are known you're out
there in the world how much
responsibility do you guys feel
um to sort of lift up others like
yourself so like is the the weight
there's so much weight
on all of you guys because you're you're
at the top
so jim talk to me about that like you
know do you feel that sense of
responsibility
oh i think it's i think it's really huge
i think that um you know my
responsibility i feel
is is to share the mic
is to bring other people provide
opportunities
for other people within my community and
outside my community
that i know that have not been
represented
and so um it's
it's and also there are not
that many well-known filmmakers with
disabilities
so i'm i so i i
feel like you know boy i
better not screw up it's like
you know it's but it but it's well
beyond that it's just
you know i'm looking forward to the day
where many of us
are known for our work
and um and so it's so
that it's um so i'm not being terribly
clear here but i think my
my point is that when we are leaders
it's really responsib it's important
that we take this
very very seriously and try to help
others
yeah exactly lisa you said that you were
quoted as saying you know we don't need
an inclusivity writer um
uh i believe that that was your quote
elaborate on that
well i can i i'd first like to jump in
and
talk about your question roger about
responsibility
um you know what my parents always
impressed upon me
is that responsibility comes with
accountability
to your community one of my favorite
speeches is from dr martin luther king
and it's called the drum major instinct
and he says that you know it's it's you
can be as
you know a star you can be
you know all these wonderful things
but if you cannot be of service then
you know that is what is your
greatest responsibility that's my
responsibility
and you know i love it because he's like
it doesn't matter if you can't do all
these wonderful things you can
always be a drum major for justice
you can be a drum major for peace
you can be a drum major for
accountability
and um i i if people don't know the
speech i'm not doing it service because
it's so beautiful and eloquent but
it is something that is is one of my
important guiding
principles um now um you know you're
when i i made a a comment about like we
shouldn't
need to have inclusivity writers we
shouldn't
need to but because it shouldn't
be the addictum to
have cast and crew
that is reflective of the
world that we live in the a world that
is not
centered in in whiteness um
a world that is not centered that
in in one gender um
and it shouldn't be the the exception
like
you know that oh wow we've done this it
should be the norm
that the all the beautiful faces that
i'm
seeing in this conversation that i get
to see
representatives of our communities
working
on our projects so um
you know for clarity it's like we
shouldn't have to have it
but until things change we should
because obviously the people who are
making decisions and green lighting
projects
are liv are seeing things through
historically a very narrow
um prism i mean in 1963
the naacp went to hollywood and said
would you at least please hire one negro
on your production so yes we have made
progress but there is tremendous more
progress that
that needs to be made and if it needs to
happen via a writer
to give awareness to the incredible
talent that is out there
but hasn't had the opportunity well then
so be it
here here yeah you know um
listening to jim um i think
you know part of what you're describing
is is what
you know roger and lisa will be familiar
with is the black tax
right you want to be better
because you don't want to mess it up for
everybody else
and and i i see nods and i so i see
people feeling that
and and i think what is important to
recognize about that
is most of us kind of willingly take
that on right
i want people who who look like all of
us to
to because i know how hard it is to do
what we do
i want i want to mentor everybody i want
to answer every phone call i want to do
all those things
but it is taxing and when our skill
is creativity and you know
focus it's it's really becomes a lot
in order you know you find yourself
spread too thin
out of the desire to help and so i do
think
as much as we um you know and i know
lisa helps everybody
you know like lisa is constantly
you know answering phone calls answering
questions i know all
you know i don't know about but i i i'm
thinking that if
all of us do that and and i think that
there's um
something we should be thinking about in
doing that like if we're spending
25 of our time doing that
um it's 25 less time doing
good work and and it does take a toll so
you know we're supposed to be honest
here
um you can't really be as
selective in your health as you would
like to be because you're trying so
desperately
to give help where it is needed and it's
so needed and such a wide
variety so that that's one thing i'm
just thinking about i'm wondering what
how you all deal with it and what what
you think the other thing is
i am very excited about the academy's um
you know best picture
requirements it's not until 2024
and we will see what happens but i think
we have an opportunity now
you know we have these next few years to
make
that not a check the box situation but
to make it a real
you know substantive um kind of
field building because that's what i
want to see i want to see the
field seated and built so that
you know there's so many people of color
and people of abilities and people from
geographic backgrounds that
you're just picking the right person for
the project instead of
you know and and i think we all want to
be known for our work
i don't want to be picked because i'm a
black woman as proud as i am of that
i want to be picked because i'm suited
to the material
for any number of reasons for my style
for my
you know whatever so um so i i guess i
just throw
that out to to all of us too well
well don i want to let's talk a little
bit about that because
can i can i sorry touch upon this
question before
we move on uh it will continue on to
what was done saying
i think what you know when when we ask
that question who's the best person to
tell the story
and we do you know these projects get
picked in terms of
someone from that community immediately
a lot of people just want to discredit
and discount
that experience as being valuable and as
as as some sort of as a skill set to
bring to that
project in many ways and and what jim
was saying
i you know i um there was a great burden
for me to tell the story of b
water uh because it was bruce lee and
as an asian-american male uh being
having the privilege
to to tell the story of bruce lee i i
saw it as a privilege because
we don't have so many heroes so many
stories so many myths that we can take
for granted
like other people do right we have to
sadly um succeed and
and knock it out of the park a lot of
the times because we don't have these
opportunities so much
and i think um what don was saying too
about like
having the responsibility to kind of pay
it forward but not
always having the time for ourselves to
do that right and i think in many ways
us doing our work being authentic is a
way to pay it forward because we're
we're helping build lanes helping build
space for the future for people to see
that
oh if you know bao was able to make a
film about an asian american
and make it be about his asian
american-ness that just
creates more kind of ideas and we're
we're working in a space of imagination
sometimes right in film so
we want to build more spaces for
imagination and for
and for us as documentary filmmakers
imagine realities
and i think like when we're talking to
other filmmakers who
might be white male uh that have more
experience
they're not judged in the same way
because they don't have that same
type of background and again we don't
value representation and we don't value
experience and lived experience and how
that contributes to the project like
how our pains our struggles relate to
that story
and i think that's so important and when
we think about quote unquote diversity
and representation like
i feel like i can tell bruce lee's story
in an asian-american way
because i've i've been harassed i've
been you know
discriminated as an asian-american and
although
other filmmakers who are not part of my
community can understand it can they
feel it and i think that's important
yeah don the
you know the um we we know that
in the industry there are um
whenever there's a a black project with
with black content
there's a list of five you me a few of
them
i feel like i should just call you and
be like if you want to do this
but i i just want to talk about that
because it's so crazy why is
why did they go to the same five people
they think we don't know
like guess what yes there is a black bat
phone and we pick it up after you call
we're like did they call you do you want
to do it what do you think
oh are you busy okay who should we give
this to i i mean
yes what were you what was your question
i just i just like
you know um how do we open up the field
like how do we
what do we do to change that i
it desperately needs to change i mean
i've had this conversation with so many
people
and and trying to say hey like i feel
like i'm not going to mention this
filmmaker's name
um because i don't know if he is getting
all the calls but i feel like
i send people so many times
to like a few people and i don't see him
getting those
jobs and i'm like
yeah no it it needs to change no i
i um but also like i feel like
i can't change it you know like
and and that is part of a frustration
is um is
i'm worried about my own career like i'm
not a teacher anymore
so you know you all and by you all i
mean
people with the ability to say you
person you should do this movie
do your own work and train your own
folks and do it for real you know
like there are such talented people
and that is why you know and we should
talk about this that is why there is so
much anger and hostility
when a person without experience
gets to do a premium project and that is
why
you know individual people beloved or
not
aside that is why that frustration
happens because
we as as makers of color are told so
long
i can't take a chance on that first time
filmmaker because this is so important
so when that rule is not applied to to
people who are of european descent
um and i say that very specifically
because i'm reading cast and i now know
the word caucasian is made up and white
is a
construct of colonialism and castism
um but so that is why that is so
enraging because yeah you can
when you want to and so what is it going
to need to take for you to want to
i don't know if it's just like um
turning down a bunch of things you know
maybe we should use the black bat phone
for that
[Music]
well you know a lot of times it's it's
um
like you did like you passing the name
on but it's also forcing those buyers
because you have power now
to force those buyers use work with this
filmmaker
you're going to work with this filmmaker
and make them work with that phone i
think that's
what you're doing with your company
right is saying
you know okay i'm going to be the ep but
i'm going to choose the filmmaker
and so create shifting the dynamic so
that you have to actively
dismiss the person and and in doing so
dismiss your judgment
as as the leader of the project so i
think that that is
hopefully something that you know we can
move to um
but you know i i feel like
i feel like we need to get a lot of
these make you know
buyers in the room and say you know i'll
just speak for myself i do not i have no
joy in being
the only not that i'm the only but do
you know what i mean i i have no joy and
not
because that means um
that's just not what what it should be
you know
um anyway yeah no can i
can i talk about my experience for a
second here i
certainly even as a i was a sound mixer
still i am
for many many years and but as a just
person with a disability
i always came into things thinking i've
got to prove that i'm not incompetent
like i i i live under this
fear that people will look at me and say
gee i don't know if that guy can do the
job simply because i'm
sitting in a wheelchair and the
experience with [ __ ] camp
i [ __ ] camp was made by myself in nicole
nina
a very experienced wonderful documentary
filmmaker
and our collaboration that
part of the collaboration that i thought
was
pretty amazing was that here was this
able-bodied
filmmaker working with someone who uses
a wheelchair
and she could see all the things i
wasn't able to
access simple things like
networking parties that were up a flight
of stairs
and and such and it was really our
allyship
but her allyship to me that
really helped enabled me as a first-time
director
to really be a director and and producer
with her on this project and um
so i i just think that that is a kind of
an important thing to think about
i wouldn't be i wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for
for you know her and how we were able to
craft a collaboration
but jim she wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for you and you know it totally
breaks my heart to hear you
say you know because i i think many
people have had those same feelings of
you know i i'm a fraud or you know i'm
going to be
you know thought of as not as not you
know good enough and your reputation is
so stellar that just
you know i i find that surprising so i
you know really um value you saying that
i remember when jason did um when i walk
jason yeah and there was
uh you know the new york sundance um
party for direct for directors in new
york city
and it was he gets there and it was up a
very narrow creaky flight of stairs
so what was meant to be a celebration
of all of us who were thrilled to be
accepted by the sundance film
festival and you know he he you know
somebody
eventually carried him but like that's
not how he wanted to enter the room
you know there was a loss of control of
it a little bit of loss of dignity for
him
to you know to have to ask and then you
know have
all of all these accommodations that
should have been and easily could have
been
worked out before either find another
place
or make sure that he's you know situated
um early enough so he doesn't have to
come into the room
you know and and fee and and i i could
see it he was angry he was
you know upset he couldn't walk you know
come into the room triumphantly the way
that he should have to celebrate his
accomplishment
so um you know that is
i i think it's important for people to
hear that
those experiences so that hopefully
you know and and i i know it's a burden
because it's a burden for me
and for all of you to constantly inject
race and you know you know things
sometimes you don't want to just talk
about those things you want to talk
about everything but
but i i do really value you continually
reminding us because a lot of i think
behavior that is offensive or
off-putting is not intentional
and so you know i think people need to
be reminded
of their own blindness like roger is
saying with you know prudence you need
you there was just a learning curve
there so like you having us all describe
ourselves
i love doing it as you can see a little
bit of the actor in
me um and just the fact of you asking
for us to do that very simple thing
hopefully that will encourage other
people to think of that when you're not
in the room or on the zoom
i mean i think there's a part of this in
which we
are filmmakers and artists but we're
also activists
and and that um
it would be nice to be able to maybe be
more of an artist
certain days than than an activist
for my community and for other people
yeah
let's talk a little bit about allies and
um
so there's where does the responsibility
lie you know they're um
there's been some calling out of um
white filmmakers
who've um helicoptered in and
were and told stories about um uh people
from underrepresented communities
um the work around that um
has been has been done by like brown
girls doc mafia
and a docs and all of these are is it
our responsibility to educate is it our
responsibility to
actually you know help people understand
the issues or are is there does some of
that responsibility lie
in the white community um i'd love to
lisa
to talk about like that because it seems
like
all the work is being done by these
these organizations
and i don't see that much coming from
the the people who
actually hold the power people who have
the white privilege i don't see
that coming from from them i see the
work coming from
people of um people from
underrepresented communities
and and what you see is is
proof positive you know of the
difficulties that we have
um i'm i'm kind of tired of doing the
work
i'm i'm tired of being 300 percent
um and i think probably all of us
and so many of the people that we prize
in our community
feel the same way you know when i when
someone says they're an ally
i don't need you to be my ally because
that means that you're
almost infers you're doing me a favor
you know
i want you to be someone who is in
lockstep
for with me for change for access
for opportunity for extending
beyond the five black directors who
uh or any kind of directors you know
who uh and and and
that you are seeing your privilege
you're you're sitting with your micro
aggressions
your um you
are making the change as a gatekeeper
and realizing that
you have fallen off the wagon you
haven't done your homework
um you know there is certainly something
to be said about being in a pod for
for covid um but i think then we have to
get
out of our creative pods
and for those who have the ability
to award projects premium projects
and to extend
themselves to
new people um in our in our community
i you know i mean there you look look at
dawn's film right look at our films and
see who we hire
if you don't know who to hire that's
what i would say
you know let's just start there it's
it's we've
planted so many seeds there's so many
breadcrumbs
um but
you know there is a great amount of
frustration
about it then transfiguring
into actual work and change
yeah do do people in power
ever see their power i mean is there
are they just gonna about like
you know these gatekeepers the the the
people in in power who make the
decisions
you know are they really going to just
give up their power
you know i that that's not a question
for me to answer in a way right
but i think um lisa brings up a good
point of like the difference really
between like allyship versus solidarity
i want you to stand in solidarity with
us like we're all part of the same
community you're not
doing something for me because you're
higher up in a way
i mean yeah i my parents are vietnamese
war refugees so like my
my history of cinema and my like kind of
like
self-reflection is through kind of the
vietnam war
and that's always the way i centered
myself in many ways when i saw myself on
screen i was
a body count i was a peasant i was just
someone who
someone would shoot off a helicopter i
never saw myself exist
and i think uh people need to realize
like how powerful these
depictions are especially for young
people when they see themselves when
they see they don't exist
when they see that they have nothing to
strive for or exist
in i think we have to kind of before we
can kind of move forward we have to like
reckon the past right we have to
re-examine all the
kind of dirty truths of of cinematic
history of
of america's history and before we
kind of uh figure out how these
gatekeepers can help us quote unquote
they have they have to kind of look
at their own they need to learn from
their own past instead of us teaching
them uh
what they did to us in many ways right
yeah yeah
um i want to just talk briefly about
each of your films
um dawn um good trouble
uh do you um
such a you know obviously such a
towering figure
um what do you feel that you bought to
that film as a as a black woman
um i think a lot you know i'm really
like i'm like writing down everything
you're saying about because i'm like i'm
gonna
steal it and appropriate it and take it
as my own
um uh but you know i think
you know a few things one is mr lewis is
always described as being brave
right and when we talk about
deconstructing racism i think
one of the first things i look to is
language so
what john lewis and the other civil
rights workers did
is strategy it was all strategy how they
dressed
where they protested what things they
targeted what their demands were
how they were all going to behave they
coordinated how they were all going to
behave when they were arrested
so focusing on their intelligence
rather than just their bodies being put
in front of
a baton you know that was that was one
you know big goal but i think also there
was
you know my great-grandfather was a
pastor in a black church
and so i i think that there can be a
misunderstanding about the role of
religion
in the black community it's not just
you know a kind of god and spirituality
it's
real community it's a it's a home it's a
place of safety
it's where you go for meals and
political meetings and so
understanding the meaning of the black
church i think was
really crucial to understanding why
john lewis and the other civil rights
workers met in the basement of a church
a number of the people were were
ministers who were leading them
there's the tie-ins so you know
understanding that and then you know the
last thing i would say
is just the level of respect that you
give to elders
like nobody had to tell me you don't
call
representative lewis john like my
grandmother would rise up
and strangle me if i refer to an elder
by a first name
even if he said to do it which he never
would but just
you know i always came to him with the
respect
um that you give to an elder and that
was taught to me
from the you know time i could speak um
and and i i think he knew i understood
our relationship which is as much as he
was
kind and open and generous he was always
going to be my elder
and and i was happy for him to be that
you know
and and i think that that that helped
him relax
that helped him to want to teach
you know and i think a lot of in the
interviews it's passing on
it's that oral tradition of passing
things on
so i think all of that and that i think
is what
you know part of what bow is saying is
like all of that
i didn't have to learn uh i came to the
project with that knowledge
and so i think i i think i was the
person
to to tell that story but i did also ask
myself the question am i the person
to you know to to do this many people
can do
many things about john lewis and i hope
that they will
but i think that those were the things
those were the skills and also the
memories
and the experiences that i wanted to
lean into in telling that story
no i hear you and jim um
let's talk a little bit about um your
perspective um
making crib camp you know um for me when
i was
when i i realized after sort of six
months of being
um in zimbabwe with children with very
severe
um disabilities that when i was doing
wheelchair races with them
and um and they and they were like
fake faith healing each other and i was
felt part of the
and i realized that that they were just
like any other
kids that they were just like they were
you just wanted to have fun and have sex
and talk about girls and do all and it
and and my all that sort of broke away
i mean talk about [ __ ] camp and like
making that film from your perspective
it's just was
rough it was relevatory for me
well i mean i think that it was
revealing
to a lot of people you know we are not
looked upon as people
uh rarely are we looked upon as sexual
beings
but we have this incredible uh nicole
and i had this incredible
five and a half hours of this black and
white video footage from 1971 at this
camp
and and there's joy there and there's
there's humor and there's really kind of
deep consideration
that you just really kind of rarely
see this intimate and inside of a view
i think that one of the things that
makes our film really
wonderful is that this is really told
from the inside as opposed to somebody
really looking down upon us
and i i i appreciate that the people's
video theater
that was there 50 years ago didn't go
around the camp
going well camp director tell us about
the handicapped people
but they were right with us and they
were giving us an agency
and i originally
asked nicole if she would direct a film
about the summer camp and she said we
should
she wanted me to direct with her and
that was um that that really opened up a
lot because
when i was asking the questions to
someone within my community
they trusted me they trusted me that i
would take
what they were telling and i would do
right by them and
their their life
it was a big responsibility absolutely
absolutely um lisa
you co-directed with liz garbas um what
what are the different perspectives each
of you you as a black
latino woman black latin woman
um liz uh what did you talk about that
um you know it it was a really
interesting collaboration
ultimately we were both
passionate and committed to in
interrogating you know this history
of voter suppression in our country
which is embedded in
in racism it's it's embedded in power
and we had a hive mind
about the structure
and the approach you know our
our interviews etc but we also
had a space for very healthy
conversations
that allowed us to speak from our
unique vantage point and experiences
and it's in our personal histories
and how it intersected with the story
that we were telling
um you know i so
honor history and interrogation and
discovery in documentary films and
as does liz and i feel that
it helped us to make a story that is not
a
just spinach and good for you but it has
a lot of deep personal moments
from individuals who
[Music]
are so important of of making the change
and the progress that we've you know
has been made by teaspoons as opposed to
in greater leaps and
bounds um
so in our hive mind we found as i like
to call it we also had a space
for important conversations uh
defined by our unique experience
and you know um
privileges in some spaces and lack of
privilege in
in some spaces well you um
you're your student film julian won an
award at palm springs
uh talk to me a little bit about your
journey to be water and how easy
or not easy it was um getting to
to that to that that that the place of
making that film and
getting you know this isn't this is an
instance where
a buyer actually went to someone
you know someone who's asian to actually
tell this story
and and talk a little bit about how that
happened and
it was it was a long time coming i mean
as everyone on the panel knows it takes
a long time to make a documentary
i guess for me it was five years which
isn't too long considered
for many other documentary filmmakers
but to try to make like
a film about the most famous asian
american and not get any traction
uh i felt was a bit difficult you know
just kind of eye-opening in many ways it
took five years from
the original conception to when we
finally premiered this year at sundance
and um i got a lot of pushback because
there have been so many
bruce lee documentaries there have been
like 40
but surprisingly or maybe not
surprisingly there haven't been
any features directed by an asian
american about the most famous asian
american
and i knew that the lens that i wanted
to tell bruce lee's story was different
it was it was somewhat personal and
honest even though i don't know
bruce lee um personally uh i i knew that
my perspective was something that was
different and that could lend
uh um value to bruce lee's narrative
and um you know espn was fortunate
i was fortunate enough to connect with
espn and
they they allowed me to tell this story
in again unapologetically asian-american
way
so i think a lot of people when they
think of bruce lee he's sort of this
global cultural
icon he's transcends his race in so many
ways and he's not seen as an
asian-american
so i wanted people to know this was an
asian-american male
growing up in you know coming to america
in the 1960s trying to make it in
hollywood in the 1960s when
the vietnam war was just starting to
boil up the korean war
had ended a decade earlier and then two
decades earlier was
the um world war ii where the japanese
were in turn
so the enemy of america was very much
the face of the asian american
and i thought it was important to you
know put that
uh end to bruce lee's narrative his
mythology in so many ways because
again it's it's hard enough to be kind
of
a bipod actor actress today but trying
to be it
in hollywood in the 1960s is seemingly
impossible
but people always think that bruce lee
just was always this huge icon that he
never struggled
so to kind of understand and unpack that
struggle
i knew it was important to see like all
the moments in american history where
asian asian americans were
disenfranchised they were
ostracized they uh they
were felt as like humans as as as
american
and um again i was really fortunate to
to
explore bruce lee's life and it was it
was a testament to his character that
he didn't come to america trying to
assimilate he came to america
knowing that you know i learned martial
arts from from hong kong i'm going to
bring that side of me to america
and that's the that's how i'm going to
become american is that you're going to
accept the best side of me
and i'm going to mold that into what the
best of america can be
instead of trying to assimilate into
everyone else's idea of america
i think that's a conversation that we're
having today in many ways is like
are we bringing ourselves by by
becoming these diverse voices in a room
full of
familiar faces or are we being ourselves
an american
by bringing the best of our authenticity
our voice into what the future of
america will become
and um again i've i've learned so much
listening to everyone today and
we we all have to listen more we all
have to learn more and i think that's
something we can take away in the future
for sure
absolutely beautifully said
um well as we sort of wrap up
i i you know i'd love to just hear from
everyone sort of um
where do we go from here you know this
is we we if you
when i look out at this this panel um
all of you um are authentically
telling your story as
um from your community from your
perspective and that's a
that's a beautiful thing but we know
that that's not
the case in the industry um you know
sort of
at large so um
where do we you know
where do we go from here who does the
work
how do we you know sort of take it
beyond the sort of
symbolic diversity in this corporate the
corporate strategy as val says
of of um diversity initiatives to some
actual real
concrete change you know um
i'll just go around and i will start
with you lisa cortez
wow roger um well listen i
we want narratives sovereignty
right we want to that ability
to have unfettered access
to opportunity to telling the stories
uh that are unique from our
perspective and to receiving
distribution for those stories
i mean it's one thing to tell it's a
whole another conversation
that we haven't had about you know the
access
to the buyers um
so in that in this moment
um as we
move towards this sovereignty um
i would ask those who were former allies
but are now
in solidarity with us thank you val
uh to step up
and to to join us um
because we can expand the scope of the
stories that are out there
uh by working together
yeah here here jim
i think that um there are many barriers
for people with disabilities or who are
deaf or hard of hearing to really have a
career
and that and one of the things that i've
always thought about is that
you know if you don't can you imagine
me working if you have never seen
somebody like me
working um so we have to kind of prime
the pump here
we have to look at how people enter the
business
and if you're judging someone's
commitment
or ability by whether they can work a
20-hour day
or it can carry a tray full of coffee
for people
you're filtering out a lot of people
whose experiences
and stories we're missing out on
and uh and so you have to look at how
you're judging someone's worth
and someone's value and their talent
and um and it's not that hard to kind of
integrate people with disabilities into
this
you just have to look at how other
people have made their career
and if i'm not able to work in the mail
room
i doesn't mean that i don't deserve to
be a director
or run a motion picture studio
and fun and finally
we talk about inclusion and and such
and what's really important to me is
somebody with a mobility issue
is that i want to see somebody
with a disability if they win an award
be it an oscar or an emmy or anything
else
i want us to be entering the stage
exactly the same way as everybody else
does
none of this waiting in the wings or
it's too difficult
but that we accept the fact that if you
really
believe in inclusion that we
also get our time to enter the stage
not differently but the same way
everybody else does
um that i'm so glad you said that
that that gym because um when we won the
oscar prudence couldn't come on stage
because they said there was no
way to get her wheelchair on onto that
stage at the kodak theater
and it was they they're like we'll just
cut away to her
um and it was um it was devastating i
mean it was for her
i mean she didn't have that moment um
because it wasn't
it wasn't wheelchair friendly they're
like it takes too long it was too
complicated it was too it was just a
bunch of excuses why she couldn't be on
that stage
and i fought and argued and fought and
they still
they just wouldn't budge well i mean i
think that it's important from the red
carpet
i see that flight of stairs and i'm
thinking
you know why is that a flight of stairs
well when the kodak was designed or
anything else was done
they didn't really think about
accommodating people like myself
exactly in the same way as everybody
else oh we can do something special
or we got to lift off there
true inclusion means that i get to
hold the hand of my co-director and
co-producer
going up on that stage together the same
way everybody else does
absolutely absolutely bell
yeah i mean i think again having
conversations like these are important
right i think
uh people in power people in the
industry uh
can can benefit from listening more
right and not necessarily be defensive
when we're having these uncomfortable
conversations because i think
for us as as bipac as uh as
marginalized filmmakers in some ways
we've been
we've been feeling this level of
discomfort in our daily lives
for so long and and it's it's time to
everyone can feel a little uncomfortable
i think like immediate action is knowing
recognizing that
you creating a diversity initiative
isn't
something that's new right there's been
organizations that have been doing
this work and making space in lanes for
communities for decades um
you know the center for asian american
media uh third world newsreel
um um now today with like firelight
uh with uh adoc visual communications
brown girls doc mafia support these
communities listen to these
like organizations and that's something
that's very immediate right
um and another thing is allowing
more than one story to be told about
something uh you know uh
understanding that there's a danger in
the single story right that there
there doesn't have to be one vietnam war
film there doesn't have to be one
asian-american film about the subject
there's so many different ways to tell a
story
and i encourage people to make as many
bruce lee films as possible this is
i think sometimes people think like
documentaries are definitive historical
records and no they're
they're they're valuable they're you
know some very subjective sometimes and
i think there there's always ways to
learn more from these spaces
and you know in any
you know just not not just in our
industry
in in our society there's so many ways
that people
can help because i think i don't want to
put self-importance onto what we do as
filmmakers
but i remember watching your film jim uh
subject denise saying um laws
won't change attitudes right and
attitudes need to change
through culture through film through
books through the way we
see each other in the world through the
way we absorb each other
and so i think it's important that in
in every industry we work in we think
about changing those attitudes and then
laws can change and policies can change
um so
you know as an industry too we i don't
want to think of this type of
conversation
and these initiatives and this reckoning
as a trend
but more as a movement because this us
existing is an inevitability in so many
ways
absolutely absolutely um don
the elder statesman states woman sorry
elder states woman
and let you bring it on home
um i uh just thank all of you for this
conversation today
it um you know really has given me a lot
to think about
um i want to encourage um particularly
well i would encourage everyone to to
remember that one size does not fit all
um and so people need different types of
um not just support but respect
um so as as jim says
um you know it's not only people with
disabilities but people who don't are
not of means cannot afford to volunteer
and be interns and so you can't rely on
a path of
plucking talented interns who are
supported by wealthy parents for your
for your talent pool so you know at the
at the stage of who's entering make it
making it possible
or just you know thinking about barriers
to entry
just just having that thought just
thinking about that um
but then i think like at our level i
would encourage
people um to think about how you treat
each director i mean i have been not by
everybody
but by most people um i have you know
really good relationships but on a few
occasions i've been called very
aggressive i have been called out
for um you know kind of like
basically you know loud black woman
behavior
um in situations where i was i think
being a
leader of a team and so you know i
i kind of challenge people to uh
think about what assumptions you bring
to
your partners and you know understand
um i'm really good at my job
and if there's something you're
concerned about you should tell it to me
straight
don't try and hire a camera around me
don't ask for the resumes of the
cinematographers or producers i bring to
double check whether they're qualified
um so you know there are a lot of uh
i don't know if we would call them
microaggressions but there's
you know there's cracks around these
seams
um where you know that as
uh you know my career is great right now
and i am just thrilled at the
opportunity
and i'm running after as many as i can
while also trying to make space
um but when i
i really it's exhausting to demand
respect from people
at this stage and so i just encourage
you to
put yourselves in in our shoes you know
i think empathy
is a great um a great skill
builder so do what you need to do to
have that empathy great
i've been um giving um
a lot of executives a reading list
and um i've been at the top of that
reading list um i've
has been um ibra mex candies how to be
an anti-racist which is the number one
book on the new york times bestseller
list
because because white people are reading
it and they're like
oh okay um
i have to actually be anti-racist i just
i can't just sort of you know
just not be racist so um
it's i i you know and and i tend i give
it to executives
um because they're the ones who are
going to be
having to hire people that don't look
like them
they're the ones who are going to be who
are going to empower those people to
commission
films um and uh and
uh but i don't want and i'm like the
work is not
i can't do all the work you have to
you have to do the work you have to be
an anti-racist
um or your or the world's going to leave
you behind because we're moving forward
we're moving forward regardless um and
nothing is going to stop
progress in the world it may be slowed
down
maybe temporary you know sort of scary
moments but
it that's because progress is happening
and i think progress is happening in the
documentary community
um and uh and i and it's very exciting
and it's evidenced by all of you and
who you are and the films you've made
and what you've done
all of you are just just make me so
excited to be
in this business i'm so proud of each
and every one of your films and all your
work
and i look forward to seeing your work
for
you know terms of
for the future all the work you're going
to do in the future so
um thank you all for um
being part of the academy for the work
you you're doing
in the academy to to to to move it
forward
to move it out of the dark ages into the
light
um thank you um
and and for those of you who aren't um
bal you are
you will be an academy member i have no
doubt your work is
is spectacular uh this um
this panel has been great and thank you
all for watching academy dialogues
check out our previous discussions and
subscribe to the oscar channel for more
videos